Guten Tag. Wir sind heute hier zusammengekommen, um einen lustigen, ulkigen Podcast zu feiern und zu zelebrieren.
Anwesend sind Stefan Tietze, er legte schon im zarten Alter von 24 Jahren sein Jahrhundertwerk Was kostet Geld vor.
Es wurde mittlerweile in 37 Sprachen übersetzt und vor kurzem wurde in Botswana die Stephan-Tietze-Gesamtschule eröffnet. Und Florentin Will, seinerseits Ex-Profi-Volleyballer, keine besonderen Werke veröffentlicht jemals, aber ist er meinungsstark bei TikTok und Be Real. Keine Gesamtschule auf der ganzen Welt wurde nach ihm benannt, trotzdem ist er hier jede Woche und verkündet lautstark seine Meinung oft auf den Bauch raus. So lasst uns starten. Also ich könnte mich schon wieder so aufregen, oder? Der US-Wahlkampf, oder? Es ist ja wirklich Pest und Cholera, beides ist ja scheiße, beides ist ja scheiße, also du kannst ja wirklich, entweder das eine ist ja komplett bescheuert, die anderen sind furchtbar, also will ich gar nicht, dass wir den austauschen können, also du kannst ja beides nicht, die kannst ja beide nicht nicht nehmen, also wie willst du das denn erzählen, also das kannst du ja nicht machen. So, das war übrigens, ganz kurz, ich mag das ja immer gerne, wenn Intros einen Titel haben. Viele Leute bedienen sich ja damit, da einfach ihren eigenen Namen oder finale Intro fertig, später nochmal drüber gucken, Punkt MP3 das nennen, nicht so. So, Matthias, der hat nämlich dieses Intro genannt, vielleicht haben manche schon es erraten, denn das Intro lautet wie der Titel einer Podcast-UFO-Folge, für alle Rätselfüchse, gerne jetzt mal stoppen die Folge, könnt ihr erraten, dieses Intro an welche Podcast-UFO-Folge, an welchen Titel einer Podcast-UFO-Folge hat euch dieses Intro erinnert? Hast du eine Idee, Stefan Tietze? Nein, dann null Punkte direkt. Möchtest du einen Joker setzen? Ja. Ja, welchen möchtest du setzen? Du hast den Sombrero-Joker, den Chicken-Nugget-Joker und den Handy-Joker. Sombrero, bitte. Ja, dann kannst du dir jetzt diesen Sombrero aufsetzen. Okay. Das heisst, wenn du die Frage jetzt richtig beantwortest, kriegst du nicht nur einen normalen Punkt, sondern auch einen Tequila-Punkt. Okay, aber es hilft mir ja nicht bei der Beantwortung der Frage. Nee, es ist nur, du kriegst mehr, wenn du es richtig machst. Ja, aber dann würde ich den ersetzen, wenn ich die Antwort kenne. Du hast ihn gesetzt, das ist jetzt deine Entscheidung. Ja, dann den Chicken-Nugget-Joker auch noch. Alles klar, hier ist eine Sechserpackung Chicken-McNuggets, die kannst du essen, um dich zu stärken, um mehr Energie. Wo hilft mir das denn bei der Be beantwortung der frage na ja wir haben einfach verzweifelt versucht uns von welt millionär abzugrenzen und es ist nicht so leicht sich neue joker auszudenken das prinzip ist ja ne es ist anfangsbuchstaben sagt mir die anzahl der buchstaben das geil okay dann machen wir das auch noch dann kriegst du den aal joker für anfangsbuchstaben wieso aal will den nehmen? Begen A-Anfangsbuchstabe. Der Aal ist das erste Tier mit Doppel-A. Okay, nicht die Stadt Aachen zum Beispiel. Nein. Okay, ich nehme den Aal-Joker. So, dann kriegst du hier einen geräucherten Aal. Oh mein Gott, wir sehen so schnell organisiert. Ja, wir haben eine flotte Reaktion und du kriegst den ersten Buchstaben, nämlich W wie Wermutstropfen. Okay, W, W, dann würde ich sagen, es ist Wahlsturz. Völlig richtig, Wahlsturz, Sturz der Wale hat Matthias sein Werk hier genannt. Oh, jetzt kriege ich sowohl ein Tequila. Du kriegst einen Tequila-Punkt und einen regulären Punkt, aber du hast dafür drei Joker verwendet. Und du hast die Chick-Nuggets nicht angerührt. Aber dafür muss man sagen, der eine Joker, den gab's vorher gar nicht, also ... Das stimmt. Willst du die Nuggets noch essen, oder ist es ... Ja, gern. Dann machen wir jetzt kurz eine Pause. Boots, Bell, Bones and Balls. Boots, Bell, Bones and Balls. Boots, Bell, Bones and Balls. Welche schmecken am besten, ist die Frage. Balls, Balls, da ist mehr dran, gefühlt. Glaube ich nicht, dass es wirklich mehr saftiges, organisches, leckeres Fleisch ist, sondern es ist einfach ein Ball, der wirkt, als wäre da mehr dran. Meine Lieblingsform ist aber der Boot. Oh, Boot ist gut. Boot ist nicht schlecht, du hast immer diesen kleinen Stiefel, den du nochmal extra andippen kannst. Genau. Der Boot ist fantastisch, wenn du nicht mehr so viel Süssauersauce hast, weil am Anfang ist ja Ball supergut, weil du hast noch richtig noch eine Menge Ozean. Ich hebe mir den Boot bis zum Ende auf von den Chicken McNuggets, dass du am Ende noch mal mit diesem kleinen Stil noch mal alles zusammenkratzen kannst und noch mal alles rausholen kannst. Petition für eine neue Chicken-Nuggets-Form. Ja, bitte. Der Rechen? Ne, muss er auch mit B anfangen. Achso, auch mit B anfangen, okay. Bunker.
Bunker, mhm. Das hat eine Aushöhlung, wo du innen drin, quasi wie so ein Löffel, die Soße reintun kannst. Er ist ein bisschen dicker, massiver, so ein brutalistischer Chicken-McNugget. Ein brutalistischer Chicken-McNugget. Aber wir driften ab. Da haben wir Stefan Tietze wieder. Sein Zweitwerk wird derwerk wird der Brutalismus des Chicken McNuggets. Du bist ja eigentlich der Mitbegründer des Tietzitismus. Du hast ja den Tietzitismus. Wieso Mitbegründer? Du hast ihn ja mitbegründet damals. Mit wem? Mit Uwe Wagenknecht. Sehr uneitler Kerl offensichtlich. Das ist der Onkel von Sarah Wagenknecht. Okay. Und der hat sich irgendwann abgespaltet und hat dann versucht, mit dir eine neue Bewegung abzugründen. Warum nicht Tizismus und so ein Tizitismus? Eigentlich ist der Tizitissimus. Es ist wirklich die reine Tizigkeit. Also der Tizitissimus, warum macht man das nicht eigentlich bei allen? Wir machen keinen Kommunismus mehr, wir machen Kommunissimus. Im Sinne einer Steigerung. Ja, Isimus ist ja die höchste steigerung der superlativ superlattissimus und man will ja zu holen jetzt ist für viele leute der kommunismus ja schon zu krass weißt was ich meine das ist ja quasi so eine radikalisierung ich komme gerade vom sozialismus gerade über den kommunismus zum kommunissimus kapitalismus leben wir nicht schon lange im kapitalismus gibt ihm noch noch mal die Medaille. Stefan Tietze hat ja schon einige Preise bekommen. Zum Beispiel? Die Günther Grass-Pantoffel, die Elfriede Jelinek-Tiara, also da sind schon einige Preise, ziehen schon seine Wand. Und ich glaube, da kommen noch mehr. Er ist einer der aufstrebenden Stars. Die Wolfgang, das Wolfgang Köppen-Diadem, darauf bin ich besonders stolz. Ja, aber ihm werden. Für mich einer der unterschätztesten Autoren. Ja, wie heisst er nochmal? Wolfgang Köppen. Ah, ich habe ihn direkt schon vergessen, so kurz. Wolfgang Köppen. Okay, Wolfgang Köppen. Für mich einer der besten, völlig, völlig unter die Räder gekommen, vom, vom, vom Rat der Zeit. Vom knallharten Literaturbetrieb zermahlen auch in gewisser weise da hast du keine meinung dazu okay das weiss ich da hast du keine meinung jetzt nicht da möchte ich gar nichts mehr zu sagen eigentlich sogar auch ich würde ja sagen er wurde vom zahn der zeit zermalmt die mühlen ja ja schließt euch an, dem Tizitissimus, es gibt noch Plätze, ihr habt noch Ordensplätze frei, ne, ihr habt noch so ein Gemälde. Die Will-Theorie, der Will-Effekt. Ich versuche ja eher so ein bisschen knallig reinzugehen mit der Will-Effekt. Die String-Theorie. Richtig, ne, eher wie der Big-Ban-Effekt. Big-Ban-Effekt? Big-Ban-Effekt, ja. Es gibt ja zwei konkurrierende Theorien, die das Universum bekommen hat, die Big-Bang-Theorie und der Bigan-Effekt. Big-Ben-Effekt? Big-Ben-Effekt, ja. Es gibt ja zwei konkurrierende Theorien, die das Universum begonnen hat, die Big-Bang-Theorie und der Big-Ben-Effekt.
Die Big-Bang-Theorie kennen wir alle, aus dem Urkanal ist das Universum entstanden, alles ausgespuckt, es expandiert seitdem stetig voran.
Der Big-Ben-Effekt ist so ein bisschen, wir alle wissen ja, wie der Big Ben klingt in London, wir machen es mal ... Bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, bam, hin und her, bis sich dann letzten Endes das Universum gedacht hat, los hier! Und dann ging es los. Weisst du, was ich glaube? Ernsthaft glaube? In luftleerem Raum, zeitlosem Raum, einer unendlichen Unendlichkeit des Nichts sind wir in einem Was. Also verstehe mich nicht falsch. Wir sind nicht mehr in einem Wo, sondern in einem Was, oder wie? Also meine Theorie des Universums ist tatsächlich, und das meine ich ganz im Ernst gerade, ist... Ist das Teil des Ticitissimus? Naja, du kannst es da reinschreiben. Ich will ja nicht mein eigenes Vermächtnis schreiben, meine eigenen Theorien, meine Zitate da niederschreiben, sondern da braucht man Chronographen wie dich, Chroniker. Ja, das wird alles aufgezeichnet. Deswegen machen wir dieses Podcast-Projekt, ja. Genau, so, also, in einer Unendlichkeit, wo es keine Zeit gibt, wo auch die Zeit unendlich ist, weil nichts da ist, kann ja sehr viel passieren, weil es eine Unendlichkeit gibt. Also alles ist sozusagen wieder möglich, selbst das Unmögliche ist in der Unendlichkeit möglich. Und da, weil auch keine Zeit ist, da gibt es ja kleine Effekte trotzdem. Und da geht es kurz auf und wieder zu. Und da sind wir drin. Aber wo heisst es, du brauchst einen schmissigen Namen, so ich kann mir das nicht merken, du brauchst einen schmissigen Namen. Plumps. Okay, der grosse Plumps. Der grosse, naja, ich brauche ein Wort, was das auf und zu beschreibt. Die C-Harmonika. Ja, ja, genau, zum Beispiel die C-Harmonika. Die Gummiband-Effekt. Ja, der Gummiband. Okay, das grosse Gummistring. Okay. String-Theorie. Naja, aber ich glaube, wir sind gerade ... deswegen beobachten wir das Expandieren, weil wir sind noch in der Öffnung. Aber eigentlich ist es wie so eine kleine Blase, die auf und zu geht, wie so wenn man so einen Teig rührt und dann bilden sie ab und zu Blasen und dann plassen sie wieder.
Okay.
Und wir sind gerade noch in der Bildung, aber das kommt uns sehr lang vor, wir sind aber ganz, ganz kleine, kleine, kleine, mini, mini Teilchen für, eigentlich von aussen betrachtet ist es so ein, geht auf und zu, so eine kleine Luftblase des Universums.
Aber weil wir so kleinen, mini klein sind, ein Nanonstel, da drin kommt uns das vor wie Milliarden Jahre. Aber, und jetzt beobachten wir gerade noch das Expandieren und bald werden wir das, also nicht wir, aber so in eine Milliarde Jahren das Sinken, das Sammenschrinken wieder beobachten können. Ja, du konntest mich nicht überzeugen. Ich bin weiterhin beim Big-Ben-Effekt. Ich glaube immer noch eher an ein Oszillieren zwischen mehreren Zuständen, die dann sich irgendwann lösen. Aber gut, das werden wir heute auch nicht mehr klären wahrscheinlich. Meinst du, wir kriegen das noch hin mit einem offenen Brainstorming zum Thema Anfang des Universums?
Wie ging es los und was war davor eigentlich?
Was mich halt stört, ist, dass keine blöden Ideen zugelassen werden.
Ja, das ist ein Problem.
Weil generell merkt man ja oft, also wir zumindest haben es gemerkt, in kreativen Räumen, Brainstorming-Situationen, manchmal ist so eine blöde Hirnfurz, einfach mal rausgehauen Idee, fruchtbarer.
Gibt es diese angstfreien Räume in der Physik, frage ich mich. Gute Frage, ja. Ich glaube nicht. Gibt es viele Autorität, vorne der Dozent steht, Nobelpreis oder so. Also das hat mich ja geärgert an diesem Tweet, wo irgendeine Twitter-Userin ohne jetzt grossen wissenschaft Hintergrund, hat gesagt, können wir nicht ganz viel Beton in Vulkanen schütten, um den zu verschliessen, damit der nicht ausbrechen kann. Und das wurde dann von der Wissenschafts-Community so repostet, als, guckt euch mal an, wie dumm die ist, die Gesellschaft geht zugrunde, alle dumm und alle so dumm. Und ich dachte mir so, Leute, das ist erst mal eine Idee. Ja genau, lasst doch mal die Idee zu. Warum ist es denn eine schlechte Idee? Wie unsere Zimtidee. Wir haben gesagt, dass Zimt krebs halten könnte, was war das nochmal? Ne, dass Zimt den Flugverkehr CO2-neutral macht. Also wir haben gesagt, es wurde jemals Zimt in die Tanks gekippt, haben wir gesagt. Haben wir einfach nicht immer die gesamte Lufthansa-Flotte mit Zimt betankt und gucken, was passiert.
Guck, was passiert. Das ist ja genau diese Offenheit. Der Luftraum ist ja, das ist ja Blue Sky, sagt man ja auch zu offener Improvisation. Da kannst du ja einfach da mal Blue Sky dann testen, ob die Flugzeuge vielleicht nicht schneller fliegen. Ja, ja, genau. Weil warum nicht? Wurde noch nicht gemacht. So, und deswegen sage ich, wie viel Beton brauchen wir, um alle Vulkane zu stopfen? Bei Vulkane, vielleicht machen die auch die Atmosphäre warm, und wenn die alle eingestopft sind, vielleicht ist auch eine Art Klimawandel zu lösen. Mit der Lava, rein damit! Deine Idee, dass alle weisse Hüte tragen. So, das ist schon mal Punkt eins. Weil es gibt sehr viele Milliarden Menschen, es gibt unzählige Menschen auf diesem Planeten. Nagel uns jetzt nicht auf eine Zahl fest. Und wenn alle einen weissen Hut trögen, würde es dazu führen, dass wenn die Sonne schöne auf die Hüte, die getrögen würden, das weil weiss reflektiert und schwarz, zum Beispiel schwarzer Asphalt, sehr schädlich für die Temperatur der Erde, heizt sich alles auf. Okay, auf der anderen Seite, die Menschen werden ja immer älter, das heisst, die Haare werden ohnehin immer weisser. Super. Das heisst, das ist ja eigentlich ein Effekt. Die Erde heizt sich selbst. Es gibt weniger junge Leute, mehr alte Leute, die weissköpfig rumlaufen, die müssen halt jetzt nur noch raus. Die müssen jetzt halt sich irgendwie auf so ein Fussballfeld stellen oder sowas in der Richtung. Ja. Und dann, wenn weisse Menschen gut für die Erde sind, jetzt kommen wir natürlich in problematische Gefilde ein. So, das, nee, nee, stopp, da wurde ich, glaube ich, falsch verstanden und das ist auch, da würde sich, ich würde mich da als Tizitissimus auch davon diszenzieren von solchen Ideen, weil das ist dann problematisch, aber ich habe ja immer noch die Idee von der, ah, wer du, warst du? Fuck. Okay, zum Glück. Also, Stefan hat eine Mail bekommen und nach unserer Regel, unserer Disziplinarregel, muss man als Strafe die Mail vorlesen, um eine Lektion fürs Leben zu lernen. DHL-Paket. Ihr DHL-Paket wird gleich zugestellt. Hallo Stefan Tietze, ihr DHL-Paket wird voraussichtlich innerhalb der nächsten 15 Minuten zugestellt, jetzt live verfolgen, beste Grüße, jetzt handgeschrieben, also so den Anschein erweckend, als wäre man ein Mensch, ihr DHL-Team. Spannend, ne, dass man da nicht Helvetica nimmt, sondern eben so wie so eingescannt ihr DHL-Team als so eine Signatur quasi reinsetzt. Das ist die herzliche menschliche Wärme, die ich auch von einem Lieferanten erwarte. Dafür mache ich es ja. Aber dann schreibt Mirko oder Ahmed oder so, aber nicht ihr DHL-Team. Also das ist dann sofort wieder, es wird sofort wieder abgerundet, sofort zurückgezogen, Corporate.
Ich will eigentlich wie bei so, wenn man in der Firma Geburtstag hat und irgendwie die eine HR-Person geht rum und sammelt Unterschriften von allen. So will ich eigentlich, dass alle DHL-Mitarbeiter unterschrieben haben, wirklich so oder dann so mit so einem Smiley oder jemand macht ein Herzchen oder so. Das fände ich irgendwie gut. Macht man zu selten. Stimmen diese Namen, stimmen diese, ich spreche von Volt, Lieferando, wo man immer steht so, Tim ist auf dem Weg zu dir. Ja, nein, die stimmen nicht. Stimmen diese Namen, stimmen die Uber-Namen? Ich glaube, das stimmt nichts. Stimmt das nicht? Das stimmt nichts. Ich bin ja auch mit Rollern unterwegs, die haben auch alle Namen und ich habe da auch mal nachgeguckt, die haben alle, die heissen alle anders. Emmy, he-I, heissen alle E-M-I. Die heissen alle anders. Aber bei mir ist es tatsächlich so, ich bin so Spam-gebrandmarkt, ich glaube keiner Mail mehr. Und ich habe letztens wirklich DHL, ihre Sendung konnte nicht zugestellt werden, ist woanders hingegangen. Ich konnte dieser Mail nicht glauben. Ich dachte mir, nee, das kann nicht sein. Das stimmt nicht. Aber irgendwann musste ich dann doch realisieren, dass tatsächlich die Wahrheit sprach aus dieser Mail. Es war tatsächlich so, aber ich bin so durch mit Mails. Ich kann keiner Mail mir glauben, wirklich. Die meisten auch User, auch Hörer-Mails und so. Ich bin so im Spam-Modus, dass ich immer sofort, sobald er steht, Hallo lieber Florentin, weg sofort, sofort, kann ich gar nicht glauben. Ich bin so paranoid, ich kann überhaupt nichts Nettes mehr annehmen von Leuten, weil ich so mit Spam bombardiert werde den ganzen Tag.
Ich habe auch immer die Angst, zum Beispiel wenn man Leuten schreibt, jetzt zum Beispiel habe ich für unser Intro-Vorhaben Klaus Badelt geschrieben, tatsächlich.
Wie hast du ihn erreicht? Kann ich nicht sagen. Also ich habe wirklich, ich habe überall, also mein ganzes Tissi-Tissimus-Netzwerk angezapft und am Ende ist tatsächlich eine Mail und eine Mailadresse unten rausgefallen und an die habe ich geschrieben. Und mein … also Text war für mich fast Nebensache, viel wichtiger war Wörter zum Schiffen, die Spam aussagen könnten. Du meinst, Klaus Brandt kriegt auffällig viel Spam? Nee, ich meine, man muss halt aufpassen an fremde Mails, ähm, gerade als Erstabsender, ähm, habe ich eine Spamangst. Ich habe Angst, als Spam abgestempelt in der Ecke zu liegen. Sagt aber auch viel über dich aus, ne? Natürlich, klar. Aber ich, das ist jetzt ja auch, ich bin auch gebranntmarkt vielleicht, aber ich meine, das ist ja seriös. Am Ende des Tages ist es aber eine fremde Mail von einer fremden Adresse mit einer ein bisschen unseriösen Anfrage. Und da hilft auch Filmorchester Babelsberg nicht. Also das Podcast-UFO, also UFO hilft, glaube ich, schon nicht für Spam-Content. Das stimmt, da haben wir es uns damals wirklich, wir hatten ja das Podcast-Ufo oder das Comedy-Shuttle und rückblickend hätten wir uns vielleicht für das Comedy-Shuttle entscheiden müssen, weil man dann eher Vertrauen erweckend hat. Das Spam-Ufo oder so, das Spam-Podcast. Das Viagra-Podcast, wollten wir uns eigentlich ursprünglich nennen, aber das hat dann leider nicht so ganz geklappt. Nee, aber ich finde, als Firma oder als seriöser Auftritt im Internet sollte man damit planen, nicht im Spam-Orden zu landen. Beispiel, ich war mal im Hotel und wir als Freiberufler sind darauf angewiesen, die Rechnung zu bekommen. Ich weiss, dir ist das immer egal, aber dafür bin ich viel zu knickerig und ich reiche das ein. Es wird alles abgesetzt und da bin ich auf die Rechnung des Hotels angewiesen. Und die kam von so einer Unteradresse des Hotels. Und das war so eine Mail, die war so x5jbzhx55at und dann der Überanbieter.de. Nichts an dieser E-Mail hat gesagt, klang nach dem Hotel, in dem ich übernachtet habe. Und das ist halt sowas, wo ich denke, das geht halt nicht. Also in einer Zeit, wo wir alle Spam-Opfer sind, kannst du so keine Mail schreiben. Nee, das Vertrauen ist komplett verloren für mich mittlerweile, ist komplett weg. Ja, ist komplett weg. Es könnten alles Bots sein, könnte alles KI sein, überall lauern sie schon. Worüber haben wir gesprochen, bevor meine
Mail uns Jäh unterbrochen
hat?
Kriegen wir das noch hin?
Kriegen wir diese Gedächtnisleistung,
dieses akrobatische Meisterwerk noch hin?
Diesen Doppeln-Rittberger
der Gedächtniskunst, das finde ich
immer beeindruckend. Es gibt ja so Gedächtnis-
Weltmeisterschaften auch, wo die
Besten antreten und die sitzen dann
alle so an Tischen und die müssen sich dann so
Kartendecks, gemischte Kartendecks,
Die Reihenfolge auswendig lernen und solche Sachen. Und ich habe mir diese Doku angeschaut und ich war so angespannt und so gestresst und ich war so, weil die sind halt so krass, dass die halt in dem Raum irgendwie drei Stunden lang sitzen und die machen dann Aufgabe nach Aufgabe und Decks und hundert Decks merken die sich oder was auch immer und ich werde wirklich der, der sagt, ah, nee, ah, ah, ah, shit, ich hab nix und dann bin ich der einzige, der aufsteht in dieser riesigen Halle und dann durch alle durchgehen und so, tschuldigung, sorry, sorry, sorry, die sind alle in ihrem Mind Palace irgendwie unordnet.
Das heisst ja, man muss sich dann Raum vorstellen, wo man dann sich so umguckt und dann hat man,
muss man sich so witzige Sachen überlegen, also das sind ultra witzige Leute, wo man dann sagt, du musst ja,
der Goldfisch ist ein Stück Käse und irgendwie dann die Tür, da ist eine Strumpfhose drum herum gespannt und so merkst du dir dann, dann steht Strumpfhose steht für Ass und der Goldfisch steht irgendwie für Karo acht und so merkt man sich das dann alles in der Reihenfolge. Das heißt, diese Gedächtnisleute müssen einen unglaublichen Raum in ihrem Kopf haben, wo sie alles dann unterbringen. Weil anscheinend Menschen sich extrem gut Dinge in Räumen merken können und visualisieren können, aus Angst wahrscheinlich vom Wolf.
Ja, ich habe auch mal damals, als ich Sherlock gesehen habe und wo es ja oft um den Gedächtnispalast geht, mich so ein bisschen eingelesen in diese Gedächtnispalast-Theorie. Mhm.
Und das ist ja die gleiche Idee.
Du baust dir einen Raum visuell, nimmst Dinge, die du kennst aus der Kindheit oder die
du schön findest oder so oder wo du halt eine Orientierung hast und kannst so einen Raum bauen und dann kannst du da in zum Beispiel farbigen Schatullen Informationen ablegen an Orten, die du dir merken kannst. Und da habe ich so einen, so einen Test, so eine rosa Schatulle mir damals gebaut, in so einem Raum. Ich habe mir vorgestellt, so eine Bibliothek, so ein bisschen wie man sich das vorstellt, so aus Harvard oder sowas. So finde ich spannend, finde ich visuell ansprechend. So habe ich mir gebaut und ich weiss noch genau, wo diese eine Test-Schatulle liegt. Kannst du sie mal live für uns im Podcast öffnen? Nee, möchte ich es nicht. Aber da ist ... Das heisst du, Moment, du weisst, was drin ist. Da ist was Privates drin. Warum merkst du dir denn was Privates? Als Test, als ersten Test. Moment, aber was könnte jetzt so privat sein? Dein ... Geheimnis. Pincode oder aber es war nur ein Test. Die Person, in die du heimlich verliebt bist, die musst du dir extra da merken. Aber so ein, nee, nee, das war nicht, um es mir zu merken, sondern es war mehr als so ein, weiss ich nicht, also wenn man jetzt einen neuen Laptop bekommt oder man probiert mal ein Programm aus und schreibt kurz was und dann testet man das mal. Und dann schreibst du den Namen deines geheimen Schwarmes mal direkt testweise auf dem Laptop. Ja, so ein Pin, genau. Und das liegt da jetzt noch. Aber sonst ist alles leer. Also man muss sich vorstellen, jedes Regal ist leer. So, als würde man kurz vorm Auszug steht noch diese eine Schatulle da total traurig. Aber was ich meine, es ist schon gruselig, das ist ein grosser Raum. Und ich weiss, wo die Schatulle liegt. Und sonst ist alles leer. Und ich weiss, was da drin ist. Und das kann ich mir seit, weiss ich nicht, zehn Jahren merken. Klar. Das ist halt nur eine Sache, ne? Ja, aber diese rosa Schatulle, auch wie die aussieht und diese Farbe, das kann ich mir schon alles sehr gut vorstellen. Und die liegt halt da rum. Das ist sehr auffällig auch. Die steht am Boden oder hat die so eine Art Podest? Nee, die ist tatsächlich in einer Falltür, die gar nicht in diesen Raum passt. Moment, Moment, in eine Falltür? Ja. Also du stellst dir einen riesigen Raum vor. Bibliothek. Die Schatulle ist dann aber noch in einer Falltür. Rechts, man geht rechts und dann nochmal rechts. Da sind dann so Tische, wo man sich hinsetzen kann. Manche lernen da und lesen, da sind diese grünen Lachen auch. Da sind Leute drin? Klar, laufen da rum. In deinem Mind Palace sind andere, ist das so ein Gemeinschaftspalace? Ja, ja, das ist ein Social Raum. Ist das so ein Coworking Space? Du teilst dir das mit anderen Leuten? Was sind das für Leute? Meine Leute sind laut, stören nicht. Ich kann mir keinen eigenen Mind Palace leisten, ich hab mich da halt eingemietet, da sind schon andere. Ein Co-Gedächtnispalast. Memory Space, ja. Aber du weißt schon, was eine Falltür ist, eine Falltür geht nach unten. Richtig, Falltür ist, wäre das falsche Wort, es ist eine Klappe im Boden. Okay, das ist doch eine Falltür. Ja. Aber du hast doch gesagt, rechts rum. Genau, rechts rum, rechts rum und dann ist am Boden, da muss man manchmal Leute wegschicken, die sich hingesetzt haben. Moment, wo die Leute arbeiten und rumstehen, da hast du eine Falltür. Ist das nicht sehr gefährlich? Als ich das gebaut habe, waren die da noch nicht. Okay, also du schaust da immer mal wieder rein und mittlerweile sind da andere Leute in deinem Mindpalus. Ab und zu laufende Leute. Die haben das besetzt. Ja, und dann kann man da rein, macht man die auf und dann ist da diese Schatulle drüben mit dem Geheimnis. Aber wie tief muss man greifen? Ist es direkt unter der Oberfläche? Direkt. Direkt unter der Oberfläche? Es ist wirklich lächerlich. Ab oben ist so ein Ledergriff und da kann man so rausziehen. Das heisst, selbst wenn du die Falltür jetzt mal offen lässt und die Leute da rumlaufen, die würden nicht tief stürzen, das wäre eher so ein Ohr. Ich glaube, das sind so Statisten im Kopf, die Teil von mir sind. Ich glaube, die sind eher in meinem Team generell. Okay, mir geht es um die Sicherheit, nicht, dass die da reinfallen. Ach so. Ja. Nö, passiert nichts. Aber kannst du ja nutzen, die können dann lustige T-Shirts haben, wo dann irgendwie dann wichtige formeln draufstehen oder sondern kann sagen drehe ich mal um aber kann ich nachvollziehen ich habe tatsächlich irgendwann mal so einen taschenrechner bekommen der ein bisschen krasser war den konnte man so aufklappen wie ein laptop aber so ganz rudimentär der konnte halt so logarithmus und ganz krasse sachen und sowas und der hatte auch konnte man auch text eingeben und er so eine kleine Tastatur und da konnte man Text hinter dem Passwort verstecken. Und ich natürlich irgendwie mit elf Jahren habe dann auch meinen geheimen Schwarm hinter diesem Passwort versteckt. Weil ich mir dachte, das ist mein grösstes. Frau Karskensin. Frau Schablotzki habe ich ja, ich liebe Frau Schablotzki hinter dem Passwort und ich fand das rückblickend so gut, einfach dieses, das vergisst man ja nicht, also warum muss man das überhaupt aufschreiben? Also es gibt viele Probleme, die mitschwingen bei einem Crush, der unerfüllt bleibt. Ja. Ihn zu vergessen ist wirklich das geringste Problem, wenn nicht sogar die Lösung.
Ja, ja, das stimmt. Eigentlich willst du es so schnell wie es geht vergessen.
Ja.
Und dieses Geheimnis erinnert dich ewig daran. Vor allem, es ist auch nicht gut, das in die Realität zu holen. Dann können die Leute trotzdem ja finden. Jetzt hast du es natürlich sicher, wenn du dein Passwort versteckt. Eins, zwei, drei, Kartoffelbrei. Pst, hör auf jetzt, das habe ich auf dem Flohmarkt verkauft. Ach, ja, aber ich habe diesen Palast erstellt, um zu prüfen, damals halt so ein paar so YouTube-Videos angeguckt von so Gedächtnis-Geniuses, den erstellt und dann nicht mehr benutzt. Ich glaube, tendenziell, das ist schon möglich, wie du sagst, wenn man sich Geschichten überlegt und es sind Details. Kleine Details, die einem helfen, dann sozusagen, weil im luftleeren Raum nicht zu erinnern.
Ich fände es nur interessant, wie man dann wieder aufräumt, weil ich kann mir das schon vorstellen, du stellst, keine Ahnung, bei dir zu Hause, stellst dir alles voll mit Goldfisch und Parmesan und Stück und da ist eine Goofy-Statue und die hat einen Grünhut auf und halt dieser ganze Quatsch. Und dann kommt aber das nächste der Karten und dann denkst du dir so, jetzt muss ich alles aufräumen, weil du vermischtest doch dann.
Woher weisst du, dass jetzt plötzlich da nicht mehr Goofy steht, sondern Darth Vader, der hat einen Maiskolben statt einem Lichtschwert, aber da steht ja der Goofy noch rum, weil ich bin sehr schlecht im Zimmer aufräumen, ich räume mein Zimmer nicht gut auf, da stehen noch alte Sachen rum und ich hätte halt Angst, dass mein Mind Palace irgendwann halt so vielschichtig besetzt ist und ich das Zeug von davor nicht rauswerfe und dann noch uralte Sachen rumstehen habe und dann mache ich es falsch. Ja, das ist eine gute Frage, das verstehe ich. Ich weiss nicht, wie man das dann einfach löscht. Ja, andererseits, andererseits, keine Ahnung, ich weiss jetzt nicht, wie Magic funktioniert, aber angenommen, wenn du ein neues Spiel hast, also du hast ja während eines Magic-Duells ja Gedanken, Dinge, die du machen möchtest, vielleicht, oder ist es immer glückbasiert, was du für eine Karte du ziehst? Du redest von einem Kartenspiel, Magic the Gathering? Ich wollte dich jetzt reinholen, das ist ein bisschen gebackfired. Wenn du einfach so ohne Kontext sagst, ich weiss nicht, wie Magic funktioniert, denke ich mir, ja, niemand weiss, wie Magic, das ist die Idee. The Gathering, ich dachte, bei dir kommt dann The Gathering. Ich dachte mir so, das ist ja die Idee, niemand weiss, wie Magic funktioniert. Nee, ich meine nicht Zauberei, ich meine Magic, The Gathering, MTG. So, aber da, angenommen, du bist in einem Duell, sag mal Duell, Partie, Spiel, sag doch, wie es heißt. Ja, ein Spiel. Spiel, okay, Runde. Eine Partie. So, und da hast du ja auch wahrscheinlich taktische Gedanken oder Dinge, die du gleich machen möchtest oder sowas. Du überlegst dir, ich weiß nicht, es ist ja nicht alles nur glücksbasiert wahrscheinlich, welche Karte, du hoffst ja auch, die und die Karte kommt gleich. Meinst du, diese Metapher hilft dir wirklich? Dir. Ich versuche dir zu helfen, deswegen habe ich ja deine Welt, etwas aus deiner Welt genommen. Aber ich habe gerade gemerkt, dass es vielleicht ein bisschen zu komplex ist dafür, für die Metapher. Weisst du aber noch, was ich erklären will? Ja, ich habe es direkt vor mir. Ich spiele eine Partie Magic the Gathering. Und jetzt, das ist ja das Äquivalent. Ich spiele Grün-Rot. Das ist mir ganz egal. Grün-Rot, aggressives Ramp, aggressiv. Spielen die Ramp oder nicht, also da ist mir ganz leicht. Okay. Ich meine nur, dann bist du in der nächsten Runde, du denkst ja nicht mehr an die Runde davor. Ach so, aber spiele ich dasselbe Deck nochmal? Ja. Ja, aber dann ist ja meine Strategie ähnlich wie im Spiel davor. Wisst ihr, und da habe ich jetzt gerade gedacht, vielleicht ist das das falsche Beispiel. Ähm, ja, okay. Ich meine nur, du bist ja schon in der Lage, die Partie davor zu löschen aus deinem Kopf. Aber ist das ein Best-of-Three? Also habe ich ein Sideboard, kann ich mein Deck verändern? Wie gesagt, das ist mir total egal. Also das ist mir so egal. Okay, okay. Mein Gott, so ein Gedächtnistrainer, der so richtig aggressiv ist. Ich habe auch mal so, ich habe ja Doktor Kawashimas Gehirntraining gemacht. Kawasaki? Ne, Kawashima. Aber gut. Ne, also wenn ich den Namen Doktor Kawashima vergessen hätte, dann hätte der Mann seinen Job nicht gemacht, okay? Und das lasse ich nicht zu. Doktor Kawashimas Brain, Brain. Wie hieß das nochmal? Doktor Kawaloppi, Karhm, Karamasi, ach, so, da weiss man direkt, das funktioniert nicht. Aber ich habe gedacht, Dr. Kawasaki ist Gehirntraining, aber es ist Dr. Kawashimas Gehirnjogging. Ja, du, ich kann dir wirklich Dr. Kawashimas Gehirntraining, kann ich dir wirklich empfehlen, ich finde es nicht. Und das habe ich auch immer gemacht, das heisst, ich hatte dann Super Mario und Dr. Kawashimas Gehirnjogging auf meinem DS und habe das immer gerne gemacht. Das Ding ist nur, man musste damals, hatte man gewisse Übungen, die man einmal am Tag machen sollte. Die Idee ist, du machst das einmal am Tag und dann bleibt dein Gehirn frisch und saftig. Wie so ein richtig saftiger Speck, der so richtig ausläuft in der Pfanne. So richtig saftig. Und dann wollte ich es aber nochmal machen. Ja dann hieß es, nee, das ist die tägliche Übung, die darfst du nur einmal am Tag machen. Und dann dachte ich, ja wie, ich will weitermachen, ich will weiter joggen, ich habe noch Kraft in mir. Und dann habe ich beim Nintendo DS in den Einstellungen das Datum geändert auf den nächsten Tag und dann hat er gesagt, ah, ein neuer Tag, sie können jetzt ihre tägliche Übung machen. Und das habe ich halt wirklich gemacht, so dass ich mich wirklich mehrere Monate in die Zukunft gearbeitet habe, gejoggt bin quasi. Ich bin quasi am Zeitstrahl vorbeigejoggt. Und irgendwann verschwimmen aber deine Traumrealität, in der du bei Doktor Kawashima bist, und die Realität. Ja. Und du feierst Silvester bei dir allein im Zimmer und die Eltern machen sich Sorgen und so, weil du es nicht auseinanderhalten kannst.
Und irgendwann ist es aber wirklich so, bei dem Nintendo DS hast du deinen Geburtstag auch eingeschrieben und irgendwann sagt der DS, alles Gute zum Geburtstag. Ja, und lädt Verbräume ein. Und hat ein Geschenk für dich gekauft, hat halt so eine Flasche Wein. Ja. Und du denkst dir, ach nein, das ist alles gelogen, das ist alles falsch. Ich lebe eine Lüge, Mama und Papa, ich lebe eine Lüge! Kleiner Tipp, falls ihr euch einen Account macht bei, also wir haben über Thema Essenslieferung. Was? Wo kommt das jetzt her? Dann gibt es ja sowas wie Lieferando, ne? Dann hat aber oft einzelne Ketten haben auch nochmal ihr eigenes, ihre eigene Website, ihren eigenen Auftritt, ihre Plattform. Und das ist ja dann oft so ein Krieg, ah, ist die noch bei Lieferando oder nicht mehr, muss ich auf die eigene Plattform. Es gibt da so einen Unabhängigkeitskrieg zwischen dem grossen Omega-Terion-Lieferando und den kleinen Kalifaten. Das Vereinigte Deliveroo-Königreich. Richtig. Deliver Hero oder wie heissen. Und dann machst du so bei, jetzt sagen wir mal hier, Happy Pizza. So, sagen wir mal, gibt's nicht, goog googles nicht. Vielleicht gibt's es doch, aber dann kannte ich's nicht.
Happy Pizza, machst du den Account, willst eine Pizza bestellen, zum Beispiel eine Pizza Hawaii, weil du weisst, was drauf ist.
Und dann musst du deinen Account anlegen.
Kleiner Tipp, als Geburtstag, mach mal nächste Woche.
Mach mal nächste Woche.
Als Geburtstag. Ja. Du musst dir ja dann nicht unbedingt die Wahrheit sagen. Mach mal nächste Woche. Mach mal nächste Woche. Als Geburtstag. Ja. Du musst ja dann nicht unbedingt die Wahrheit sagen. Mach mal nächste Woche. Und dann bestellst du an deinem Geburtstag. Und dann bestellst du was und dann eine Woche später kriegst du die Nachricht, alles gut zum Geburtstag, sie kriegen eine kostenlose Pizza. Zack, zack. Ist das Betrug? Ja, weiss ich nicht. Vielleicht, aber ich sag mal nur so, überlegt euch das mal.
Boah, ich, das hab ich euch schon mal erzählt, aber ich hasse, ich hasse mein Fitnessstudio dafür, dass die mir jedes Jahr als Erste gratulieren.
Jedes Jahr erste Mail an meinem Geburtstag, generell die erste Nachricht vom Handy, ist mein Fitnessstudio.
Wünscht mir alles Gute, du kannst dir das Geschenk an der Rezeption abholen.
Ich finde das ein vergiftetes Geschenk für jemanden, der nicht mit Menschen interagieren möchte.
Ich finde das sauschlimm.
Oh, das ist richtig. Und dann habe ich gedacht, das erste Mal, wenn ich da hingehe und mich einwähle,
am Anfang, wenn man ins Fitnessstudio geht, dann macht man ja dieses Ding, dieses Piep und dann geht das Ding auf und dann kann man reingehen, Das ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, das erste Mal, wenn ich da hingehe und mich einwähle, am Anfang, wenn man ins Fitnessstudio geht, dann macht man ja dieses Ding, das Piep und dann geht das Ding auf und dann kann man reingehen, dass die dann sehen, an ihrem, da haben die so eine Party-Tröte auf ihrem Computer und dann so, sie hat einen Geburtstag, hier, bitteschön, eine Flasche Wein, Proteinpulver. Proteinwein gibt's ja auch. Proteinwein.
Und nee,
und das erste Mal hab ich noch gedacht so,
ja, ich zahl ja hier regelmässig meinen Mitgliedsbeitrag,
der werde ja wohl mal ein Geschenk bekommen dürfen.
Und dann bin ich hingegangen und hat gesagt, ich hatte Geburtstag.
Und die so, ah, okay.
Ja, und dann ist sie nach hinten gegangen,
in diesen Geschenkraum,
und so lieblos hab ich dann sowas bekommen. Lustigerig aber wirklich eine Flasche Wein. Wirklich? Ja. Und die stand dann die ganze Zeit neben dir, als du dann trainiert hast, oder was? Die habe ich dann in den Spind gepackt, ja. Und dann aber alle anderen in den… Nee, ich bin dann mit der Flasche Wein, das wäre so lustig. Du hattest die dann nach, du bist auf so einem Fahrrad gefahren und hast die Weinflasche so in den Getränkehalter getan und inzwischen drin immer wieder getrunken.
Aber alle anderen wissen ja, dass du Geburtstag hast dann, weil alle anderen, die machen dasselbe, wissen alle, du hast Geburtstag, weil du die Flasche Wein hast und dann immer so. Jetzt bin ich ja schon drei Jahre oder so und die letzten drei bin ich nicht mehr hingegangen, weil ich das zu affig finde. Geh doch mal an einem Tag hin, wo du nicht Geburtstag hast und sag, übrigens, ich habe in der App eine Nachricht bekommen, ich habe Geburtstag, ob du auch eine Flasche Wein kriegst. Ah, und dann einfach jede Woche mal hin. Einfach immer Weinbetrug. Ich glaube, Geburtstagsbetrug, da kannst du richtig was rausholen. Okay, das ist nicht Teil der Lehre des Tecitesimus. Ah, okay, aber Teil des Will-Effekts. Des Will-Effekts. Will-Effekt predigt gleich Geburtstag betrügt. Wir haben als Oblaten haben wir Oreos, jeder kriegt einen Oreo in den Mund. Ganzen Oreo? Kompletten Oreo. Wer zahlt diese Oreos? Wenn jetzt zu viele Leute sich an uns anschliessen dem Will-Effekt, dann kann es sein, dass wir während dem Gottesienst merken, heiliger Vater, wir haben nicht genug Oreos. Und dann sage ich während der Predigt, dann teilt sie, wie Jesus. Also meint ihr brechen? Nein, oben, unten. Okay, sorry, sorry, noch mal eine Frage. Ja, was denn? An der einen Seite ist ja dann die Milchcreme und an der anderen nicht. Nee, nee, wenn du davor ne, ne, wenn du da vor dir zusammendrückst ein bisschen. Was dann? Dann kannst du es auf beide Seiten mehr aufteilen. Drehen, nicht so pflücken, sondern drehen. Beide sollen den gleichen Anteil Milchcreme haben. Gleich ist jetzt utopisch, aber ungefähr gleich, dass beide was haben. Beide sollen dieselbe Milchcreme haben, ja. So, dazu komme ich in Psalm Nummer 800 gleich und selbst. Wann haben Sie die geschrieben? Wann haben Sie die ganzen Psalme geschrieben? Die habe ich heute Morgen geschrieben auf der Autofahrt hierher. Außerdem glaube ich, Psalm ist geschützt. Nein, wirklich? Das Wort Psalm ist geschützt. Ach, dieser fucking Matthäus, oder? Matthäus Psalm. So, teile die Oreos in zwei Stücke und guck, dass die Milchcreme auf beiden ist. Dieselbe Anzahl. Go, go, go. Go.
Verbeugt.
Statt gehen in Frieden.
Go, go, go.
Lauf, lauf, lauf.
Raus, raus, raus, raus, raus.
Der Letzte wird abgespritzt.
Lauf, lauf, lauf, lauf, lauft.
Ich liess gerade ein Buch über die Jesuiten.
Ah!
Ja, so ähnlich habe ich tatsächlich auch reagiert, weil ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, wir sind ja so möchtegern intellektuell manchmal und man überlegt sich dann Sachen oder schaut eine Doku und bestellt dann auf Amazon das Buch. Und dann drei Tage später, man hat das Thema vollständig vergessen. ja plötzlich plötzlich ... Ich meine, natürlich habe ich es vergessen. Ich dachte bis gerade, es heisst Doktor Kawasaki's Gehirntraining. Und dann hast du drei Tage später dieses Buch in der Hand und auf Amazon kriegst du ja nicht mit, wie dick das Buch ist. Du denkst dir einfach, das ist halt ein Buch, aber dann hast du es in der Hand und es sind halt einfach 1200 Seiten, die Jesuiten und du denkst dir, ach, ach ja, das wollte ich ja auch noch lesen. Ich denke mir, im Zweifel macht sich das saugut im Bücherregal. Wirklich? Klar. Glaube ich nicht. Macht es das? So ein dickes Jesuitenbuch? Die meisten Leute wissen nicht mehr, was das ist. Eben. Ach, geil. Geil. Ja, ja, ja, ja. Das ist immer so, welches Buch liegt auf dem Nachttisch, ne, das ist ja auch immer, weil die Bücherregale ist ja eine Sache, aber Nachttisch ist so, ah, damit beschäftigt er sich gerade, wo man dann auch wirklich stark kuriert dann auf dem Nachttisch Bücher präsentiert. Sagt nicht, du hast noch nicht vor einer heissen Erotik-Nacht kuratiert, was auf dem Nachttisch liegt. Und dann aber Achtung, das Lesezeichen, immer ein gutes Stück nach hinten.
Niemand will, dass das Lesezeichen auf Seite acht ist, weil die Person denkt, ah, du kannst gerade mal drei Seiten und die Widmung lesen.
Was super lange auf meinem Nachttisch lag, was mir jetzt einfällt, nie gelesen, bis heute nicht, inzwischen auch im Bücherregal, aber das lag lange da, weil ich es immer lesen wollte, war The Agony and the Ecstasy über Michelangelo von deinem lieben Freund Stefan Natzen, war jemand empfohlen mir, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das kam, aber von Irving Stone und über sein Schaffen und seinen Prozess und so, über Michelangelo, The Agony and the Ecstasy, ein wahnsinnig tolles Buch, sagen alle. Steht drauf. Und dann lag das, hat auch dieses flammende, diesen flammenden Titel und diese flammende Buchcover. Und das lag dann da. Generell so Diogenes-Verlag-Bücher oder so, das macht sich immer gut. Reklam finde ich, das ist zu gelernt. Nee, das ist zu schulhaft, das ist zu knabenhaft, das ist so Penela-Literatur. Nee, nee, das will man nicht. Aber so ein schönes Diogenes- oder so ein Surkamp-Buch. Ja, DTV ist natürlich auch, das ist dann schon sehr hoch, aber. Nee, aber das macht sich sehr gut auf dem Nachttisch. Das ist richtig gut. Macht das mal. Und dann oben so ein Lesezeichen in die Mitte stecken, so ins Letzte Drittel. Ja, ja, genau. Letzte Drittel ist immer gut. Das Letzte Drittel ist besser. Kurz vor dem Register. Genau, weil Hälfte sieht zu willkürlich in die Mitte gesteckt aus, letzte Drittel sieht aus wie, ah, okay, er ist bald durch und hat das sich drauf geschafft.
Ja. Dann ist natürlich, ihr braucht ein gewisses Wissen schon, um so die ersten drei Rückfragen vor dem Liebesakt dann doch beantworten zu können.
Man könnte das so auflaufen lassen. Ich weiss nicht, ob tatsächlich Leute sich bewusst sind, wie viel man Leute auflaufen lassen könnte. Wenn man bewusst auf das Buch im Nachtisch zeigt, ah, das habe ich auch gelesen, da wird er eigentlich eher so ein bisschen als ... Boah, kalter Schweiß auf der Stehen. Da wird er tatsächlich eher so ein bisschen auch als, naja, jetzt nicht irgendwie Betrüger dargestellt, aber dass viele seiner Werke tatsächlich gar nicht von ihm sind. Komm doch wieder ins Bett. Ich fand es ganz spannend, weil du hast mir letztens erzählt von Dumm Vinci. Würdest du sagen Dussel Angelo? Also kann man das dann auch? Ich höre deinen Podcast. Boah, ich würde jetzt viel lieber gerne, dass du hier ins Bett kommst. Ich würde viel lieber mit dir schlafen. Ja, okay, gut, mit deinem Charme kannst du es dann oft aus der Situation noch gut rausschaffen, das stimmt. Ich will gerade viel lieber mit dir schlafen, als deine Scheiße zu hören. Als dieses Gespräch vorzusetzen. Das ist ein guter Satz, den man immer einsetzen kann eigentlich. So, also da haben wir doch schon ein paar Regeln jetzt. Geburtstagsbetrug ist okay, macht das und vorteilhaft und ein guter Satz ist es, ich würde viel lieber mit dir schlafen, als dieses Gespräch hier zu führen gerade. Aber ich habe ein bisschen Angst, dass der Tizzi Tissimus so ein bisschen in Pick-up-Artist abdriftet. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, das? Das ist wie gesagt auch nicht leere, das war gerade, das war gerade ein Ulk und Scherz.
Dogma, oder was?
Dogma.
Okay.
Nee, das Hissi-Tissimus ist, boah, ich habe wirklich Bock, so eine Dogma-artige Bewegung zu führen.
Total.
Weil, ich meine, und wir waren bei guter Arbeit damals auch kurz davor, wir waren so manchmal so sehr pedantisch, was die Themen, also bevor es berg up ging mit den Klickzahlen und wir diesen von den öffentlich-rechtlichen Zwangsgebühren finanzierten, denen da oben gesagt bekommen haben, ihr braucht ja 60.000 Klicks. Du meinst kurz danach, als wir 40% unseres Jahresbudgets für einen Drachen ausgegeben haben, CGI für einen Drachen. Ja, das ist jetzt ja hier im Lahrum, Drachen schmachen.
Wie, ihr wollt einen Drachen im Sketch?
Ja, okay, das kostet halt.
Können wir zwei haben?
Ja, und da hatten wir so ein paar dogmatische Regeln, wie zum Beispiel manche Gags waren nicht erlaubt, die man schon ein paar Mal gehört hat und so.
Und ich bin ja, wir sind schon pedantisch, wir beiden, und schon manchmal ganz gut also ich bin wirklich fan von dogman ja aber wir haben manchmal auch gebrochen ich erinnere mich eine ein verbotener gag war wenn der voiceover sagt das ist stefan tietze er hat zehntausend euro schulden bei der bulgarischen mafia ich habe zehntausend euro bei der bulgarischen mafia genau das die person das dann noch mal sagt Das haben wir aber, glaube ich, auch mal gemacht irgendwo. Ja, aber Dogma, das Spannende daran ist ja auch, dass man es dann bricht. Ist das das wichtigste Dogma? Aber ich glaube, ein Gag, wo wir es wirklich durchgehalten haben, den nicht zu machen, und der wurde, glaube ich, direkt am ersten Tag verboten, ist, jemand sagt einen komplizierten Namen. Gesundheit. Richtig, genau. Sag mal, ich bin ja ein Riesenfan von der zweiten Sinfonie von Shostakovich. Gesundheit. Der ist zu Recht verboten. Welchen Gag? Ich dachte neulich, der verboten gehört. Ja, okay, sehr gut. Gagverbot. Ist, dass, ah, ich habe euch noch gar nicht bemerkt. Und dann anf zu sprechen. Oh shit, oh fuck, den darfst du mir nicht nehmen, Stefan. Also dieses, man nimmt nonchalant ein Video auf, oft irgendwie im Werbekontext oder sowas. Scheiße, Stefan, bitte tu das jetzt nicht, tu das jetzt bitte nicht, ich brauche den. Und dann sagt man so, aber du kennst es, ne? Ja, ich nutze das regelmässig. Und dann so, oh, krass, ich habe euch ja noch gar nicht bemerkt. Ja, dann kommt mal mit, ich zeige euch mal. Und das ist hasslich, wie die Pest, weil alle machen das, ich kann das nicht mehr hören. Neulich auch in einem Podcast gehört, in dem auch gesprochen, darüber, was sollte man verbieten, was geht nicht mehr. Und eine Sache, die sie verbieten wollten, ist, dass sich in Dokus, dass man zeigt, wie sich jemand hinsetzt in der Doku und dann kommt die Klappe.
Und dann kommt noch die Klappe und so und immer wieder das Mikrofon angecheckt und der sagt so, ah, laufen wir schon? Und das ist so overused. Aber ich liebe das, ich mag das. Ich will ein Antidogma, ich liebe das. Es soll in jeder Doku immer sein. Ich meine auch diese Thomas Winterberg-Dogma-95 Dogma 95 Richtung, die dann diese Filme gemacht haben, wo keine Special Effects und sowas, also die Dogma 95 Bewegung, selbst die haben, glaube ich, keinen Film zustande gebracht, der nicht gegen mindestens eins, eine Regel verstößt. Von daher, ich glaube, es ist immer auch schon mitgedacht, dass man dagegen verstösst. Ich glaube, der Wille zählt. Ich finde, Gags, die zu häufig gemacht wurden, sollte man lassen. Und ich finde, ich habe noch gar nicht bemerkt.
Shit, okay. Da muss ich mir was Neues überlegen. Da muss ich mir wirklich was Neues überlegen. Authentizität. Wie wäre es mit Authentizität? Ist dir schon mal aufgefallen, dass alle Wörter, die schwer auszusprechen sind, institutionalisieren Authentizität, dass die Silbe, über die man stolpert, ist Titz. Titz. Instituts, es ist genau deine Stolpersilbe, du bist Stefans Stolpersilbe, dass man genau da drüber stolpert. Ja, das stimmt. Das heisst, ihr könnt das üben, indem ihr einfach Tietze beherrscht und dann habt ihr auch Institution oder Institutionalität, Institutionalität habt ihr alle drin. Authentisches Institutionalisieren. Habt ihr alles dann drin, wenn ihr einfach jeden Tag morgen beim Aufwachen, beim Zähneputzen schaut euch tief in die Augen und sagt Tietze, Tietze, Tietze. Glaubst du, man sagt seinen Nachnamen häufiger als die engsten Freunde? Ja. Glaubst du, du hast deinen Nachnamen häufiger genannt als ich deinen Nachnamen? Ich glaube nämlich nicht. Ja. Ich glaube schon. Standen Sie dem Opfer nah? Ja. Sollte man erst die Milch, so als Anwalt, so eine Frage, so eine... Wie beim Lügendetektor, so ist heute Dienstag. Ist heute Dienstag. Und da denke ich mir immer, wenn jemand sagt, ist heute Dienstag und es ist Dienstag, ist heute Dienstag und die Person sagt, ja, Lüge, Lüge, Lüge. Weil du nämlich bei Doktor Kawashima schon Mittwoch hast und es für dich kein fucking Dienstag ist.
Börder, stark.
Naja, also lest The Irony and the Ecstasy, dann könnt ihr mir endlich verraten, um es dinge. Ja, bitte, wir brauchen eine kurze Zusammenfassung, die man schnell lesen kann.
Aber eigentlich auch ein nettes Spiel, Lügendetektor und man muss versuchen, immer zu lügen. Also man sagt die Wahrheit, aber man muss versuchen, dass der Lügendetektor das als Lüge registriert. Man muss also Schauspielern, dass man lügt, aber man lügt gar nicht, ob man das hinkriegt, dass man enttäuscht. Das ist übrigens, wenn ich mir sowas ansch anschaffen sollte wie du irgendwie den ohrenmikroskop oder diesen schlauch den du dir mittlerweile oral einführst ich habe mittlerweile noch eine andere körperöffnung gefunden die ich gerne glaube ich dass du noch eine körperöffnung gefunden dass du dinge einführst das was nächstes was ich mir kaufen würde wäre ein polygraphie test ist das heisst das polygraphie kann schon sein Äißt das Polygraphie? Kann schon sein. Poly ist ja Lüge. Genau, Poly... Polytheismus ist ja... Polytheismus ist eine Liebe, die auf Lügen basiert. Genau. Da haben die Griechen mal wieder Recht gehabt. Genau. Und deswegen, das wäre mir wichtig, weil ich habe grosse Angst vor Lügen, Vertrauensprobleme. Ach so, ich dachte, du trägst es selber den ganzen Tag, um mal zu gucken, wie oft man lügt und einfach mal damit man es selber mitkriegt, weil oft weiss man ja selber nicht. Wenn jemand sagt, wie geht's und du sagst, ganz gut eigentlich und dann sagt der Bip, Bip, Lüge und denkst, oh ja, ist das eine Lüge? Du willst dich selber testen? Ich will mich selber testen. Nö, nö, nö, ich will selber wissen. Ich will wissen, wie oft lüge ich am Tag, ich schneide mir das um und dann, keine Ahnung, habe ich vielleicht so einen Rucksack oder sowas auf, wo das dann drin ist. Also so dann unauffällig, so unterm Pulli kann es sein. Wo gross Lügen-Tektor.de draufsteht, weil das gar kommt mit dem Rucksack. Ja, in dieser Werbe. Mit so einer grossen Antenne. Er war auf.
Nimm raus, hier so eine grosse Antenne und dann hast du so einen grossen, ne, Hetzel. So ein blaues Licht einfach, das die ganze Zeit sich dreht und wo diese Nadel die ganze Zeit so wackelt. Und damit laufe ich dann durch die Gegend und dann gucke ich mal, wie oft man am Tag lügt, weil es heisst ja irgendwie, so und so oft am Tag lügt man, oder? Das hast du schon auch schon. Wie heißt es?
Man sagt ja immer, so und so oft.
Ein Satz muss eine Mindestanzahl an Fakten beinhalten.
Also ein Satz muss eine Mindestanzahl an Inhalt haben.
Nein, aber du kennst es doch, man hört einen Fakt und man verliert die Zahl irgendwann.
So dieses, was für mich ein Klassiker ist, ist zwei Prozent der Deutschen haben 80 Prozent des Vermögens. Du weisst, was ich meine, aber wir ignorieren mal die Zahlen. Aber du weisst ja, ob das jetzt drei oder zwei oder achtzig oder vierzig. Hier grosse Zahl denken, hier spreche kleine Zahl denken. Eine kleine Zahl Deutschen hat ein grosses. Weniger als man denkt, mehr als man denkt. Richtig, genau. Und die Zahlen, die vergessen wir mal. Und genauso ist es mit, ja, du weisst doch, dass man oft am Tag lügt.
Ja, ja.
So, du weisst ja, was ich meine.
Ja, ja, ich wüsste nur nicht, es könnte alles sein.
Es könnte alles sein.
Zwischen sieben und hundert Mal würde mich nichts wundern. Dich?
Nee, ich würde nichts wundern.
Alles zwischen zehn und hundert würde mich nicht wundern.
Ja. Naja, wie viel sagt man denn am Tag, wie viele Aussagen tätigt man denn? Wir fragen unsere neue Freundin. Ich bin kein Fan. Hi, ähm, wie oft lügt man am Tag durchschnittlich als Mensch? Na gut, dass du als Mensch noch dazu sagst, nicht jetzt als Eichhörnchen? Weil es ja kein Mensch ist. Gott, diese Scheisse. Das ist eine technische Scheisse. Also, wir schreiben das Jahr 2024, KI ist noch nicht angekommen. Ich frage an KI nochmal. Hi. Ja. Hi. Wie oft lügt man als Mensch durchschnittlich am Tag? Studien zeigen, dass Menschen durchschnittlich etwa ein- bis zweimal am Tag lügen. Die genaue Anzahl kann jedoch je nach Person, Situation und kulturellem Kontext variieren. Hast du dich gefragt, warum Menschen so oft lügen? Nein. Ja, schon. Ich habe eher das Gefühl, das ist gut jetzt. Sorry, tschau, tschau, Schatz. Ich muss los. Alles zwischen zehn und hundert würde mich nicht wundern. Es ist eins. Bin ich hier. Pass auf dich auch. Okay, du auch auf dich. Danke. Ich krieg's nicht aus. Ich krieg's nicht aus. Ich bin wie Will Smith bei iRobot. Das ist die Übernahme, ja, iRobot. Ich krieg's nicht aus. Sie hat sich gegen die Robotergesetze gewendet. Da, es ist ein Klick, ich klicke mich hier wie so ein Boomer durch. Schliess alle Tabs, schliess alle Tabs. Alle Tabs sind hinzu. Alle Tabs sind hinzu. So können wir die KI-Revolution noch aufhalten. Also, ich nüge viel mehr.
Es sind nicht, also du hast gesagt, zehn und hundert würde dich nicht wundern, es sind eins bis zwei.
Wundert mich, wundert mich. Es ist weniger, als man denkt.
Aber ich nüge viel mehr am Tag.
Na, an einem Sonntag auch mal zweimal, ne? Also das manchmal dann schon zwei.
Aber da muss es irgendwie, das kann doch nicht, also komische Statistik, komische Studie,
aber ich glaube, da gibt es einen starken Unterschied zwischen Leuten, die vielleicht nie lügen und die, die die Statistik wirklich stark nach oben ziehen. Also, wollt ihr wissen, worum es in The Ironian The Ecstasy geht? Das Buch über Michelangelo. Es gibt elf verschiedene Sektionen, das klingt alles mega spannend. Erste Station Studio, Michelangelo studies unter Gelandio at his studio.
Zweitens, der Skulpturengarten. Michelangelo studies unter Gilandio at his studio. Zweitens der Skulpturengarten. Michelangelo studiert unter Bertoldo im Skulpturengarten. Man muss beim Lesen aber auch immer die Hand machen, wenn die Namen kommen. Si. Dann der Palast. Michelangelo lives in the palace of Lorenzo di Medici, where he befriends Lorenzos Daughter Contesina. Das ist alles so toll. Schön. Reicht. Im Grunde haben wir es schon. Wenn ich jetzt gefragt werde, sage ich, ach gerade, er hat ja Contesina kennengelernt. Ach wirklich? Im Garten von Lorenzo de' Medici. Im Skulpturengarten von Lorenzo de' Medici. Ah, das war der Gönner, ne? Die haben den dann mit Geld versorgt, dass er dann seine Studien weitermachen kann. Er wird viel lieber geschlafen, als weiter dieses Gespräch zu führen. Aber ist der noch, ist der schon abgefallen vom Ruhm?
Wer? Also Michelangelo.
Viele alte Leute sind ja
langsam abgefallen, man merkt dann, ah,
rückwirkend hat er gar nicht geschrieben,
ah, das war ein Plagiat und so. Michelangelo ist noch
safe oder ist er mittlerweile schon
der alte Michel? Weiss ich nicht, bin noch
nicht beim Ende angekommen.
Also ich erwarte da noch Twists and Turns.
Okay.
Und klar, sein grosser Skandal, aber dann fängt er sich ja auch wieder.
Als er Meister Splinter getroffen hat und dann läuft's wieder. Würdest du denn als Kunsthistoriker sagen, die Farben der Turtle-Masken sind angemessen gewählt im Hinblick auf die historischen Künstler, nach denen die Turtle benannt wurden. Jetzt muss ich was sagen. Also Raffaello rot, Michelangelo orange. Weisst du das passt oder würdest du sagen, nee, Donatello müsste eigentlich rot haben und Michelangelo sollte eigentlich blau haben? Du als Kunsthistoriker. Du hast doch gesagt, du studierst Kunstgeschichte, oder? Ja. Aber würdest du sagen, die Ausweite der Farben... Aber mehr für die Studien, damit ich diesen Ausweis habe und dann kann ich ein Studententicket. Na gut, aber das ist doch deine Leidenschaft, oder? Also du brennst doch für das Thema. Nee, ich finde es okay. Ja, aber du kannst ja alles studieren, was du willst mit deinem NC. Ja, aber ... Hä, die, da war die ... Du hast ja immer so gut in der Schule. Du hast ja ... Ja, das hat auch studiert. Du hast in der Schule, hast du immer jede Party abgesagt, weil du gesagt hast, ich muss lernen, ich muss lernen, ich will einen guten NC haben. Ja, genau. Und dann hast du deinen Eins-Nuller rausgelassen und dann direkt Kunstgeschichte. Ja. Und jetzt, und jetzt, also du hast deine ganze Jugend weggeschmissen und jetzt … Sag das nicht so. Das ist wie, kennst du ja im Flugzeug, wenn man dann so schon die Reihen hinter sich hört, dass man wählen kann zwischen Pasta und Chicken. Ja. Und man denkt die ganze Zeit, was will ich, was will ich, was will ich, was will ich, Chicken, Chicken, Chicken. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Dann sagt sie, was willst du haben, man sagt, Pasta. Da hat man sich vertan und dann kriegt man das und man denkt, Scheiss, das ist dieser Druck. Das kenne ich ja. Und das war so, da haben die mich dann irgendwie gefragt und ich habe in der Reihen hinter mir schon gehört, Kunstgeschichte oder Jura, Kunstgeschichte oder Jura. Und ich habe gesagt, Jura, Jura, dafür habe ich mein Leben lang trainiert. Ich habe mich hingesetzt, gepaukt, ich war nicht feiern, weil ich den NC schaffen wollte für Jura. Dann kommt sie zu mir, sagt Kunstgeschichte oder Jura, ich sag Kunstgeschichte. Und seitdem mach ich das halt. Okay. Aber es mir, also wer ist Rot? Rot ist Raffaello. Raffaello? Und Bueno ist was? Oder Raffaello?
Raffaello? Und Bueno ist was? Oder Raffaello?
Moment, heisst der Raffaello, der heisst doch Raffaello, oder nicht?
Moment, Moment, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, die kleine Köstlichkeit wurde auch nach.
Die Teenage Mutant Kinder Turtles.
Wir kriegen nicht so eine Snack rein, also Amicelli, Ksschen, Amicelli, Raffaello, Küsschen, Messi. Mein Lieblings-Turtle ist Küsschen. Küsschen. Hi, mein Name ist Küsschen. Das hatte mir ja so ein sehr krasses Kultpotenzial. Ah, sehr schön. Ich liebe Amicelli. Ja, das wissen wir mittlerweile. Und ich glaube, du bist auch der einzige Mensch, der Amicelli liebt. Mittlerweile, ich habe, also wir haben ja vor einigen Folgen über das Thema Brause gesprochen. Ahoy, Innovationsstau in der deutschen Süssigkeitenindustrie. Du hast da harte Worte gefunden durchaus, die auch Resonanz gefunden haben. Und ein Tipp war, ahoy ist im Köpfe gerollt, der ist im Fettan.
Die ganze Kinderführungsriegel.
Da ist einiges geschmolzen, sagen wir mal so.
Und eine Sache, die da oft aufkam, war Ahoy-Eis.
Ahoy-Brause haben wir gelobt als Innovationsführer mit den Rettungsringen, mit den Brause-Waffeln tatsächlich, die es nicht mehr gibt.
Und da wurden wir hingewiesen auf das Ahoy-Eis. Ahoy-Brause haben wir gelobt als Innovationsführer mit den Rettungsringen, mit den Brause-Waffeln tatsächlich, die es nicht mehr gibt.
Und da wurden wir hingewiesen auf das Ahoy-Eis, denn es gibt anscheinend einen neuen Fürst Pückler.
Wir kennen natürlich Fürst Pückler-Eis, Erdbeere, Vanille, Schokolade. Die im Sandwich.
Die im Sandwich, aber es gibt jetzt neue Sandwiches von Ahoy und die stellen nochmal alles auf den Kopf, denn die sagen Waldmeister, Zitrone, Waldfrucht. Waldmeister, also so Wildberries. Ja, ich weiss nicht, ob es 100% stimmt, aber ne, neues Triumvirat. Nichts hinder dich nachzugucken. Neues Triumvirat, neuer Fürstpöcker. Denk so lange nach dich. Es ist der Fürst Ahoy oder es ist Käptenpöckler, je nachdem, wie wir es jetzt nennen möchten. Aber das ist die neue Verbindung und die gibt es jetzt in Sandwiches mit saurer Brause, mit Kügelchen. Und die finde ich nirgendwo, die wurde uns empfohlen im Reddit, vielen Dank nochmal an unser Reddit, da wurde empfohlen, finde ich nirgendwo, ich habe es nur in Becherform gefunden. Da gibt es immer zwei Becher immer pro Packung, was immer schon schwierig ist, weil ich will eigentlich nur einen Becher, aber dann esse ich auch den zweiten, weil ich den zweiten und dann schmilzt der, fängt er an zu schmelzen, esse ich ihn, habe ich wieder mehr gegessen, als ich wollte, nehme zu, fett, fett, fett und dann wollte ich eigentlich nur mal das probieren und schwierig. Aber das Sandwich habe ich tatsächlich noch nicht gefunden. Jemand, ein Informant meinte, es geht... Himbeer, Waldmeister, Zitrone.beerwaldmeister Zitrone, genau. Das ist Käpt'n Pückler, das neue Triumvirat. Das sieht fantastisch aus. Das sieht richtig gut aus. Und das ist auch genau so sauer, wie man das kennt von Heubrause? Muss Brause immer sauer sein? Ich finde schon. Was ist der Mehrwert? Da kann ich auch einfach Zucker essen. Also ich glaube, bei Heubrause ist doch nicht alles sauer, oder? Nee, nee, nee, das geht schon um den Brause-Effekt, das stimmt schon, ja. Aber da gibt es tatsächlich auch Pause, weil ich glaube, bei Ahoy Brause ist doch nicht alles sauer auch, oder?
Ne, ne, ne, das geht schon um den Brause-Effekt, das stimmt schon, ja.
Aber da gibt es tatsächlich auch Brause, weil ich glaube beim Sandwich, du hast es wahrscheinlich vor Augen gerade,
gibt es ja auf der einen Seite, also ne, ihr seid jetzt wahrscheinlich alle beim Big Sandwich fürs Pückler,
denkt lieber eher an das Domino-Sandwich, wo ihr auf der einen Seite Waffel, auf der anderen Seite Schokoglasur habt, also zweiteilig. So ist es von Ahoy auch aufgebaut. Auf der einen Seite Waffel, auf der anderen Seite Brausehülle. Brause, Schokolade, was auch immer, das ist dann der saure Teil. Ja, liegt es an Marketing-Füchsen, das jetzt an den Mann zu bringen oder an die Frau, weil es ist schon nicht so einfach pitchable wie jetzt so ein fürs Pückler-Sandwichandwich mit Schokolade hintendran. Du, ich glaube, es gibt eine neue Revolution des Sauren. Doch sauer ist ein bisschen sauer. Ja, ja, aber da ist auch ja was Saures dabei. Nicht alles ist sauer, aber es ist pritzlich sauer. Wir sehen das bei Hitchler, wir sehen das bei Hitchler mit den Drachenzungen, dem Drachenzungen Wassereis. Hitchis sauer, aber es gibt auch Wassereissauer, auch nicht selbstverständlich, jetzt im Sommer heississ, dass du auch mal so einen Drachen zum Wassereis aushändigst, gefroren. Ich glaube, sauer und Sommer schliessen sich ein bisschen aus. Weil sauer ist, meine ich Kreislaufanregen. Aber zu welcher Jahreszeit geniesst du denn sauer? Sauer ist Winter, Herbst, Winter. Herbst, Winter? Zur Winterzeit haust du dir einen Centerschock rein? Ja, das ist kreislaufanregend. Ich schwitz doch kaputt im Sommer, wenn ich auch noch sauer. Du haust dir doch nicht zur Weihnachtszeit, du holst dir doch nicht Spekulatius und einen Centershock. Herbst, Winter, ich rede von Halloween. Nein, sauer ist Sommer, sauer ist Sommer. Centershock ist Halloweenzeit. Da ist ein bisschen, da riecht es schon ein bisschen. Also du hast da einen Pumpkin-Spice-Latte und einen Center-Shop im Herbst. Ja, Heubrause. Aber nicht jetzt im Sommerbrause. Sauer ist Herbst? Sauer ist für mich Sommer lustig, kurzes T-Shirt, sauer schütteln, Spaß. Aber mit der Wärme, ich habe auch gemerkt, ich bin kein Wärme-Fan. Ich brauche es nicht so warm. Alles ab 25 Grad ist mir viel zu warm. Ich schwitze dann immer. Ich habe auch hohen Blutdruck, das hilft vielleicht nicht.
Okay, alles klar. Vielen Dank nochmal an Stefan. Falls ihr Lust habt auf Stefan, den Tizitissimus, meldet euch, Tizitissimus.org, es gibt noch viele Plätze. Weiss und schwarz war.
Tatsächlich, wenn Stefan Thietze euer Ordensführer sein soll, schliesst ihn euch an, folgt ihm und ja, danke dir.
Ansonsten habt noch eine schöne Woche. Tatsächlich, wenn Stefan Thitze euer Ordensführer sein soll, schliesst ihn euch an, folgt ihm und ja, danke dir.
Ansonsten habt noch eine schöne Woche, haut rein, macht's gut, bis zum nächsten Mal.
Wir heben ab, da haben wir ein bisschen Fahrtwend.